[Musique]
l'époque où mary aloni une icône du
folklore hispania se produisait sur de
plus grande synthe d'israël n'est plus
les vendredis elle vient souvent faire
le bonheur de ses fans nostalgiques ou
marché kermel jette encore manier la
fouille
il n'hésite pas à lancer des messages
[Musique]
mardi on change leur dit elle son public
est là pour profiter du soleil et
entendre cette voix qui a bercé sa
jeunesse peluche que pour causer
politique mais il semble ravi majorité
c'est bibi oriens bibi ou rien mais
rétorque que cet homme mécontent en
maraude ne veut pas plus hop elle avait
des élections législatives ça semble
être l'enjeu principal de cette campagne
doit-on confie le gouvernement de l'état
hébreu au même homme
benyamin nétanyahou un homme contre qui
pèse la menace d'inculpation de
plusieurs chefs d'accusation pour
corruption
netanyahu a voulu faire de cette
élection un référendum sur sa personne
il voulait montrer aux procureurs voyez
si la majorité des israéliens m'appuie
ça prouve que vous me pourchasser pour
des pacotilles pour des cigares pour du
champagne et des choses ridicules
le déclin qui avive boussine ce qui a
longtemps été conseiller de benyamin
nétanyahou il a aidé l'homme qui le
voyaient comme un fils dit il à se bâtir
pour devenir une véritable bête
politique à devenir presque
incontournable je ne peux pas concevoir
qu'il perde c'est un peu comme trump qui
a déclaré qu'il pourrait tirer sur
quelqu'un sur la cinquième avenue à new
york et qu'il serait comme un milieu je
crois que netanyahu est dans la même
position
on entend toutes sortes d'histoires
négative à propos de sous-marins de
corruption elia son attitude il divise
la société
les israéliens sont insatisfaits de
plein de choses mais en même temps ils
ne veulent pas prendre de risque est
passé in what we in the hunger games la
gauche israélienne
truand natanyahou c'est le sentiment de
jimmy abitbol ils se défendent idolâtré
bibi comme il l'appelle mais il votera
pour lui mardi un peu par dépit
titi je suis je suis conscient qu'il
qu'il présente des manques énorme c'est
a fait du point de vue social déjà mais
je me dis que quelque part c'est un
c'est peut-être celui qui est le plus
qualifié pour faire le job
en réalité pour tous le poids que le
personnage représente dans cette
campagne
le principal intéressé s'est fait bien
discret peu de rencontres avec les
électeurs des événements annulés au gré
de ses humeurs des entrevues accordées
avec parcimonie à une presse qui lui est
favorable
benyamin nétanyahou a préféré jouer la
carte de l'homme d'état tantôt avec
vladimir poutine à moscou
photo aux côtés de donald trump à
washington un atout indéniable du
premier ministre sortant pour séduire
les électeurs
à une semaine de la tenue du vote c'est
tout un cadeau que le président
américain a fait à son ami israélien
reconnaissant la souveraineté
israélienne sur le plateau du golan
saisi à la syrie en 1967
pour sa toute première campagne
politique benny ganz un candidat du
centre droit aura subi toutes les
attaques
les enregistrements clandestins de ces
propos répandue dans les médias des
révélations non prouvée sur ces
consultations chez un psychologue la
droite israélienne a tiré à boulet rouge
sur l'ancien chef d'état major de
l'armée israélienne
l'accusant à la fois des mulets benyamin
nétanyahou de se liguer avec les partis
arabes d'être mentalement inapte à
diriger le pays et de vouloir mettre en
péril la sécurité nationale
sur quatorze partis politiques
principaux en début de campagne benyamin
nétanyahou ils sont partis du likoud
était clairement en tête de peloton mais
selon les derniers sondages publiés ce
vendredi le premier ministre sortant est
désormais au coude à coude avec son
principal adversaire
benny ganz du parti bleu blanc
l'interprétation des sondages est un
exercice périlleux en israël mais il
semble que la victoire pourrait échapper
à benyamin nétanyahou
ce qui compte pour lui c'est lui ce
rester au pouvoir c'est
ce coupé à sa femme à ses gens assez à
faire à ces affirmations
moniteur pas au pays
megan jeu confiance de celui de
confiance de lui il a il a donné 30 ans
de sa vie pour le pays d'enhaut
militaire il
dong dur est un homme bon qui s'est
allié à un groupe hétéroclite cimentée
par la seule volonté de remplacer
benyamin nétanyahou benny ganz souder
son sort politique à celui de hyères
lapide le dirigeant du parti yasha ty
les deux hommes ont scellé leurs accords
en prévoyant de se succéder au poste de
premier ministre une alternance qui
laisse les experts et bien des électeurs
comme jimmy dubitatif je pense que c'est
un aveu de faiblesse
je leur fais peut-être pour solidifier
cette image de l'homme fort qui lui
réussit depuis maintenant treize ans que
benyamin nétanyahou a répété à quelques
jours du scrutin
que s'y livrent ils hument il poursuivra
avec son intention d'annexer les
colonies israéliennes en cisjordanie
occupée
bouchard des colonies installées sur les
territoires palestiniens occupés par
israël depuis 1967 est illégale au
regard du droit international
un obstacle majeur à la paix selon une
grande partie de la communauté
internationale
[Musique]
tout lui réussit la menthe le rappeur
palestinienne à berne à face dans cette
vidéo à propos de benyamin nétanyahou
dans ta mer contre ta mère la vedette
exprime le dilemme intérieur que vivent
bien des palestiniens notre présent et
notre avenir sont tenus en otage par un
homme très très fort by a strong strokes
mais c'est difficile d'avoir de l'espoir
la liste même si le cloud et machines et
au sol mais je manque de pièces de la
nahda la mère appelle les arabes
israéliens dont il n'a pratiquement pas
été question pendant cette campagne
électorale à ne pas succomber un
mouvement qui frange l'ampleur appelant
au boycottage des élections il ya un
risque que 15 sièges se retrouvent entre
les mains de gens de la droite fasciste
qui parle de transférer les arabes
je ne peux pas considérer ça comme une
blague je vis toujours avec le
traumatisme de 1948 c'est ce qui est
arrivé à mes grands parents
je ne peux pas dire qu'ils ne le feront
pas ils l'ont fait et le feront de
nouveau je crois je suis réaliste
benyamin nétanyahou s'est offert un
dernier bain de foule avant l'ouverture
des bureaux de scrutin au marché de
jérusalem un endroit où il est chez lui
politiquement il a une fois de plus mise
en garde de ses partisans
ap
e
vous voulez quand même
[Musique]
s'il est réélu benyamin netanyahou aura
battu le record de longévité à la tête
de l'état hébreu détenu par ben gurion
mais il pourrait aussi établir une autre
première moins réjouissante
il pourrait devenir le premier chef
d'état israélien en poste à être
inculpée et condamnée à la prison
[Musique]